community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
the findlay automotive group the
sponsors of this next segment is proud
to work with st jude's rants for
children jc fernandez stopped in to
learn more about the incredible things
they're doing for foster children take a
look
[Music]
[Applause]
well here we are at st jude's ranch for
children and we're with our good friend
it's tyler quarter he's the cfo of the
findlay automotive group it's great to
see you buddy it's great to see you jc
welcome to beautiful boulder city and st
jude's rant this is my first time here
and i'm excited to kind of get a tour
but tell us first why did you guys
decide to get involved with saint jude's
ranch well i mean it's a wonderful cause
they take care of neglected and abused
children and so i mean who couldn't get
behind that so we've been doing some
volunteer work out here with our
employees in fact if you look around on
the campus here the christmas
decorations we were out here a few weeks
ago doing all that i actually did some
physical labor and decorated some of
those trees it's very festive i noticed
all the lights it looked fantastic so
it's a wonderful cause i've got a
beautiful campus here and it's good to
have you here can you show me around
yeah absolutely so what i'm going to do
is let's go meet christina who's the
executive director here and she can tell
you all about what they do
[Music]
hi hi christina welcome come on in come
on in let's check out come on we're so
excited
to have you welcome to one of our
amazing homes so this is one of the
homes that actual children and one of
the caretakers live in yeah there's a
house parent here that lives this is her
home and kids will come and live here
and it's really a place of hope and
healing it's very inviting inside here
can you give us a little tour sure
absolutely let's check out one of the
rooms perfect daisy has some bookshelves
we've got a nice bookshelf absolutely
and
in this room
in this room is for two children so when
new kids get here this will be for two
girls they'll get to decorate their room
and they'll get clothing and all the
things that they need to make this a
warm and comfortable place while they
live with us and it's more than just
foster care that you do do you also have
job placement as well yep we have a job
training program on campus for our
teenagers and we actually have an
incredible thrift store that i think we
should go check out christina this is
one packed thrift store how does this
whole situation work no it's so
beautiful in here well you know our
community donates to us and we pick up
donations from lots of community
supporters and it's open to the public
and proceeds from the thrift store go
air yes 100 of what we sell in the store
supports our programs and we're so
grateful it's also a job training
program so a lot of the teenagers that
live here on our boulder city campus
they need job skills they need to earn a
paycheck and you know start getting
those skills and so they're able to work
here in the store doing customer service
attending to clients you know helping
price items and so it's a win-win
situation and if someone's watching
right now i know i got a closet full of
stuff i want to get rid of how do i how
do i donate how does the donation
process work yeah probably the easiest
way is to visit on our website at
studentsranch.org there's some
information there there's a phone number
we can help either coordinate to pick up
or people can come and drop it off to us
and i know after watching today there's
got to be a couple people watching that
want to volunteer their time do you
accept volunteer time absolutely we need
volunteers to help us all over this
campus including in the store so there
is room for everybody to help us here at
st juice ranch for children well tyler
we thank you and christina thank you so
much the holidays are upon us i might do
some shopping if that's okay with
everybody all right thank you so much i
appreciate it thank you so much
thank you uh findlay automotive for
sponsoring this segment this week
findlay automotive will be accepting new
unwrapped toys for st jude ranch if you
donate you receive 20 off your service
ticket jillian